would you rather be good-looking and  always have nice clothes but smell like  [ __ ] or look like a homeless person but  smell nice so basically the second part  is like being an olsen twin  the way in which people dress right now  you drab yourself up and you're a  billionaire but you smell fantastic  yeah the smelling thing is what gets me  because i sweat i'm a huge sweater i  have pities right now they are intense  but i never smell so it's not a problem  but just that the knowing of that my my  body is reaching you  eight feet away that's uh that's a no-go  the amount of comedians that have  straight  halitosis in the back of their mouths  and have no idea and like try to talk  close like a party or something like  that it's like dude you just you just  breathed awful [ __ ] up my nose from  like inches away  my eyes started twitching talking about  that i literally got too many too many  comedians just running through my head